okay
all right good morning everyone
all right so um yeah uh
well I guess at first I want to give
everybody the ground rules for what
we're doing today just so everybody
understands what we're what's happening
all right uh so it needs to say there is
to be no way we could go through all
these 27 bills in one day
um what we're what we're going to be
discussing here is that um for some of
you may or may not know but last session
uh this committee had
no floor debates except one brief
discussion about
crypto I think we had a little
discussion on the floor but otherwise
this committee is a 10-10 committee and
I have been working with the leader in
saying that what we want to do is that
we want to find legislation that we can
more than more than 10 10 can agree on
and that way we can go forward with and
um and so what we're going to be
discussing today is uh which bills have
that potential that we can go that we
can find some consensus that we can find
something that we can send to the floor
sure
um I just want
I just want to make um a slight change
to the 1010 rule which is that
um for an issue that we feel really
strongly about and that we feel that we
want to be on the floor um we're going
to go forward we're not going to
obviously do it if there's one person or
or two people but for something like
pfas
um we are going to go to P fast we've
already agreed that we want to I'm just
saying I'm just saying there may or may
not be another issue where we want to do
that well I think I think we have a
potential for a pfas solution okay okay
and that's we will take that up first uh
because I know that the uh Des has to
they have another meeting so right okay
I just don't want to Ambush you if that
turns out I I was going to qualify my
statement to be going forward here that
at this moment we have a couple of bills
uh the that that
um we wouldn't you would think might be
a 10 10 but that
um uh I I have
hopefully proven myself that I am
determined to find a solution that we
can go forward and that is the the pfas
issue okay so other than that
I I could really care less about what
happens with those special elections uh
all I care about is what happens in this
committee and also the reputation of
this committee that when we send bills
to the floor we are not going to wait to
decide who shows up that day that is
just not a good way to to run government
I don't know if you might think that's a
good thing I don't so at any rate so uh
having said that uh I just want to
emphasize that people would say you know
like uh whether you want to come and
testify or whether you're going to you
know how much discussion we're going to
have and in any of these individual
bills it's really going to be is is
um scheduling
going forward for the the next month uh
scheduling when we will discuss more uh
down and deep on any of that any
particular bill so we'll start out with
the pfas issue
um we have two pfas bills we have 242
and 465 and Mike
there you are all right
and uh and I have been talking with Mike
and and
um
didn't what's important is the es in
both of these bills Des is suppose is
the regulatory agency entity that'll
have to enforce these statutes
and
um one of the things that I think is
important and I hope we do the Democrats
think is important is passing something
that is enforceable
and that we have a state entity that is
ready willing to enforce it
um and uh and so that's why I'm
interested in here what Mike has to say
so yes representative spear
thank you uh one comment I would make
about that
I'm not so sure that whether or not it's
enforceable is the most important part
of it
I think part of it the most important
part is to get it to stop
and if we can join and have something on
the books that say New Hampshire is
against the flooding of pfas into the
state
eventually if enough States get to it
and right now there's 24 States looking
at it if we can join that has power so
I'm not so sure that just having
something that's enforceable is the most
important criteria I think it's the
power behind a lot of states
telling the manufacturers enough is
enough
okay so um uh well I disagree and I I I
I find uh over my 30 years 30 plus years
of doing this the most important of any
anything we pass
is enforceability because putting
something on the books that just simply
says you can't do it and have uh have it
unenforceable
uh is is just feel good legislation and
and I I'm and I I I feel good is when I
pass things that are enforceable so that
actually we actually can do something
about it
you're on uh thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Mike wimsat I service
director of the waste management
division for New Hampshire des and with
me I have Michael Nork who serves in our
Solid Waste Management Bureau in our um
planning and materials management and
education and planning section and then
um I also want to let you know that here
I know you've got a tight schedule today
so I don't know how deep you'll go today
but if there are questions from
committee members regarding potential
health effects and concerns about you
know why we're concerned about pfas I
have Dr Jonathan patali from our
environmental health program talks to
colleges who's who's very well qualified
to answer those questions
so by way of introduction I just want to
say that you know we the agency first
discovered uh this uh ppass
contamination in the Haven well the
peace trade Port
um more than nine years ago now that
time we thought we had a problem related
to just firefighting Foams and we
started paying attention to that we
really didn't know about these
contaminants prior to that didn't know
much about them but then two years later
we discovered the impacts of widespread
air emissions that have caused
widespread groundwater and drinking
water contamination in Southern New
Hampshire and since that time we have
been working feversely that's more than
seven years ago I'm trying to address
and understand this problem we now know
based on the work that we've done that
we have pfas is really throughout
Commerce and as a result it's in our
food it's in the products we buy and
it's in our bodies and so one of the
things we said early on became very
evident to us and I think I'm on record
in early probably 2016 17 at legislative
hearings saying that we're working hard
to deal with this and on the tail end
we're dealing with you know Water and
Wastewater drinking water trying to make
sure people aren't drinking contaminated
water but at the end of the day we're
not going to solve this problem unless
we get it out of Commerce in a way that
obviously you're not necessarily going
to get it out of all Commerce but there
are certain areas of Commerce where it's
debatable whether it's really a
necessary ingredient in the
manufacturing process and uh we're just
we're going to be fighting a losing
battle if we don't reduce the amount of
pfas in the products that we purchase
and use
so having said that I want to just say
that you know we obviously you all know
from speaking with the Department
representatives in the past that we're
never in a position to say exactly where
we're going to be on a bill to we know
what the bill says until we've had a
chance to vet it through our department
leadership and through the governor's
office but what I can tell you today is
that um as as representative spear
indicated there are a number of states
that have already passed on pfas related
legislation related to the presence of
pfas and various products there are many
more states that are looking closely at
that and an organization that that the
state has long belonged to since its
Inception the Northeast Waste Management
officials Association which is an
association of basically the the waste
executive waste directors from from the
northeast states the eight northeast
states has been working on pfas model
legislation and that went out for
comment last spring it was very Broad
and sweeping and I think the comments
that the group got have shown that
probably need to narrow the focus of
that legislation for it to really be
workable and implementable in the early
going here so we are working on that as
a matter of fact I'm headed to a meeting
there tomorrow with my counterparts in
the other states and that's one going to
be one of the topics of discussion but
in essence what we think we're going to
have is probably by December a model
legislation that's been narrowed down in
terms of its focus and what products IT
addresses by by December and being able
to vote on that so that would be
basically numoa's the organization's
recommendation for an appropriate model
legislation throughout the Northeast or
even the country and so I think that
what what we really would like to see as
an agency we'd like to see this issue
stay in play in the coming session of
the legislature so we can talk about it
so we can be informed by what numoa
develops and what the other states are
doing I think that I've spoken with the
chair about this a couple of times I
think that when it comes to something
that des and the agency can get behind
something that is as a reasonable Focus
that has implementability through the
through the participation in a
Clearinghouse if you know if all these
States passed laws with these kinds of
bans and certification requirements and
they all have a slightly different law
and they all in as a manufacturer of
business Community member you have to go
out to each one of those States figure
out what they want you to do and do it
that's just not workable we never try to
get behind legislation like that but if
we can have uniform relatively uniform
legislation that can be effectively
administered through a Clearinghouse and
we have history with this with our
Mercury band that goes way back decades
New Hampshire was a leader on that and
we really helped to drive getting
Mercury out of products which was a very
important thing to accomplish we can do
the same thing I think with pfas through
a clearing house we had a Mercury
Clearinghouse that really does most of
the heavy lifting for us so it's not a
big burden or an expense for the state
to administer that program we think we
could use that model to do the same
thing for pfas and we believe that the
Internet Interstate Chemicals
Clearinghouse which is administered
through pneumoa and the toxics and
packaging Clearinghouse which is also
administered through pneumoa we already
have good examples of how those can work
for a modest membership fee states can
participate and basically have a lot of
that notification and record keeping
burden taken off of them while at the
same time taking the burden off the
business Community because then instead
of going to a bunch of states the
business Community if they're marketing
products in the Northeast for example
just go to that Clearinghouse make their
certifications make their reporting and
then it becomes available to all the
states it's really shown to be a very
cost effective and efficient model and
we believe that with a bill that would
allow us to do that would give us
authority to participate in a
Clearinghouse and administer whatever
ban the legislature decides is
appropriate we think that's a great
model so we'd very much like to see a
bill in play for the coming session
okay so um uh I'll take a question in a
second but I just want to clear up
something
um so our situation is that we have to
have this uh uh we have to take action
by November 17th
which is prior to that December date
um will there be something that we can
use that we can pass we can get on
obviously once uh that 17th then January
the first week of January would be voted
on by the house floor and then it would
go to the Senate so that in anywhere
along that process it can be amended to
address whatever changes that it comes
out in the model legislation but can we
have something before then that we can
use to at least get it out of this
committee sure the agency would be more
than happy to provide whatever technical
assistance in drafting that that is
desired to try to get you something that
you could be comfortable with by that
time okay absolutely all right now
representative spear
excuse me thank you it may be a
modification a little bit of what you
just asked we have two bills in front of
us right now that specify the use of a
Clearinghouse for two specific areas of
products uh food packaging and carpeting
textiles
is your recommendation that we wait on
that until we can see how this
Clearinghouse is going to work and how
what no I guess what I mean is what the
model legislation looks like
sure well I I will tell you I will I
will know more in a couple of days
because I'm meeting with my counterparts
who've been working on this at the end
of this week and I think that even
though we may not the the board may not
have voted on it yet which really for
this committee probably doesn't hold
that doesn't really matter that much but
I think certainly if you're looking at
um doing something in October or
November
um we would have probably some good
language that we could help you know to
but is it still I looked at your other
model legislation just a couple of weeks
ago at least what was online and you and
I spoke at that time or actually a month
ago and at that time uh it looked like
it was Banning pretty much all of pfest
but I don't know that we really want to
do that because there are places where
it's useful I'm not suggesting that at
all no you're absolutely right it is
much broader and that was the the
comments that the that the organization
got were really aligned with that
concern I think what we're going to have
um soon is a and I believe it may
already exist I just haven't seen it is
a a revision to that model legislative
station that will be quite a bit
narrower than that original piece and
that's something we could certainly
share and help would help to inform an
amendment to one of these bills thank
you
okay so how much time do you need uh so
given this is so important to this
committee
um our first uh available day would be
October 3rd
that's a little early okay it could be a
little later than that that would be
great but obviously we'll do it we will
provide whatever systems
I mean working from Tuesday you got 3 10
or 17.
can we go with 17. we want to go with 17
okay
all right
I'm sorry did you say November 17th
October October 17th
that that well basically I had
originally planned to have everything
out of this committee by the by the end
of my end of that week but I did not
realize that we had all the way out to
November
so now that I know that we have November
I have no problems setting that 17.
that's a proposal date for for the
subcommittee to work on that coming up
with uh some resolution to this so what
I'm assuming is that
um
you too will stay together glued
together like Elmer's I don't know if
Elmer's just got P fast in it
yeah work this out and so that when we
get to the 17 that you can be just as
happy and and and I have to be frank
what appeals to me most about this is
that we're not just targeting two
products
where this is pfas
hopefully we'll solve this polymer you
know one polymer versus two or more
polymer issue I don't know if that you
guys have resolution on that yet but
I'm not sure I want to know yet there's
been a question about you know what's an
appropriate definition and that is a
little nettlesome it's important we will
have that worked out I don't have I
can't tell you exactly I can't recite
what I think the exact definition should
be for this but but we'll that's some
that's something we can sort out
certainly okay okay sounds good and
we're not understand we're not trying to
ban all pfas because there are places
like space stations and stuff where it's
perfect I just heard that honeywell's
new Freon has had it has a one polymer
pfas in it so John if there's if there's
something out there that that I'll be
clearly the marketplace is created as a
result I'm trying to get pfas out of it
and that this is where it is and and I
hope I hope it's this and again that's
the reason why I like this legislative
Clearinghouse concept
and we all did and it's in both of the
bills that we have and
haven't sponsor okay
this you can't be then
what day would you be here on the 10th
you could be here on the third you know
that's a little tight for him okay
so so but in terms of your thoughts
please yeah please send it send a text
to the you know send an email to the
committee appreciate that okay uh
everybody okay now P pass all right so
we got we got through two bills thank
you very much gentlemen thank you Mr
chairman
okay
all right now we'll go back to the
beginning of the schedule all right
first up is
um House Bill 225 relative to
prohibiting the use of currency that
could be detrimental to privacy rights
um
did anybody here want wait and I I'm I'm
okay with interim studying this issue
just simply so we can keep it alive that
we can always be aware of some some
crazy thing that occurs that we as a we
can then come next year we can urge to
have legislation pass if something
occurs so representative spear
besides recommending that we itl this
I've spent many too many hours over the
summer investigating what this bill is
and what the implications are and I've
talked about implications and I don't
want to talk about that again
the bill exists in a set in a place in
the RSA that protects privacy for
transaction types in other words loans
and various different types of loans it
doesn't in any way try to Define what a
legal currency is which is what this
bill tries to do this bill is trying to
Define what legal tender is the United
States has a legal tender it is the
dollar it is the only legal tender and
coins being a subset of dollars
the other part to that is the bill
mashes together loan transactions credit
card transactions and cryptocurrency
transactions cryptocurrency is a barter
it is not money it is not legal tender
loans are not currency they are loans
credit cards are high risk loans
other kinds of loans like mortgage loans
or low risk loans and they all have the
characteristics of some of the things
that this bill wants to ban
those characteristics are already there
you have very little privacy with a
credit card loan you have a lot of
privacy with a mortgage loan but not
that much
when the Federal Reserve issues dollars
they are not private they are anonymous
big difference if you drop a dollar on
the floor anybody gets it it doesn't
make any difference
when you when the the Federal Reserve
used to issue bonds to personal people
like me or anybody
in 1982 they were prohibited from doing
that a bill was passed the regulation
was passed saying that if you're going
to issue a bond to an individual then
you also have to keep track of the taxes
on the interest
Federal Reserve said
screw that
and said no we will no longer deal with
the public and they don't and they have
not
the Federal Reserve also our dollars are
the National currency and the only
legitimate currency of 12 countries and
six
uh what do you call it the territories
the United States doesn't really nearly
change the characteristics but the most
important thing about this and why it
seems to be getting mixed up with
somebody's idea of what's going on in
China I can't even begin to understand
but the most critical part of this I
think I think you got your point across
one okay why don't we hear from the
sponsor and to have okay have
him convince us why
why we shouldn't we should uh keep this
bill alive at interim study rather than
killing it all together because of where
it is in the statute and what you
identifying in the statute
uh thank you Mr chair for the record
replica pull it right up uh you can see
me I'm a hugging mine okay uh for the
record rep Mike Belcher out of Wakefield
um I don't know if you received I had
had a printout that I had copies made I
don't know if that was delivered down
yet yes thank you excellent
um
when this was first introduced this
could easily have been seen as as
Cutting Edge or outside of this sort of
mainstream
however I would note at this point if
you were to look at that paper at this
point many people
um including presidential candidates
have outright called for the Banning of
a central bank digital currency because
of the implications that it could have
on the freedoms of Americans
um so this is this is not a radical
issue it's it's now a very mainstream
issue in fact a bill was just introduced
in Congress that would have a similar
effect to this one although I I don't
have a lot of Hope for a passing in
Congress anytime soon
um to address some of the points that
were just made uh the the the point of
the bill
um is certainly not intended to Define
what a currency is that is that is way
outside the scope of what we're seeking
to do with this
um what we're looking to do is very
simply to protect the rights
of New Hampshire residents
to use an official currency whatever
that official currency may be
without being without there being any
capacity for the federal government the
Federal Reserve or any third party
through which a quasi-official currency
may be issued to automatically or
remotely block a transaction
which is a feature of programmable
digital currencies
to be able to uh to to avoid having such
currency
arbitrarily inflated or expire
which is something we have seen
programmed in digital currencies Central
digital currencies in other places China
would be one of those places we also see
at this point the development of a
potential supranational digital currency
through the IMF
uh so that's another route that this
could eventually take
um so that that's where this is trying
to address it's not it's not a bill
about trying to address or Define
currency it's about trying to protect
the rights of your individual citizen to
go out and anonymously conduct their
business without the government knowing
everything about it and without the
government being able to block it
that's all
yeah
go ahead Keith
so I know this may seem like a fringe
issue
um one of the best tools to learn about
how this is advancing around the world
is the Atlantic Council
right so I'll just read a couple of the
bullet points here
130 countries representing these are key
findings from their study of this issue
130 countries representing 98 of global
GDP are exploring a central bank digital
currency
19 of the G20 countries are now in the
advanced stage of cbdc development
11 countries have fully launched the
digital currency China's pilot on and on
and it goes on but
uh this is this issue technology
advances very quickly and it takes us a
little while to catch up and this is one
of those moments where we're trying to
catch up to this uh because it is
happening around the world and
there are just there's discussions of it
happening maybe at some point here we
don't know exactly what it's going to
look like is the issue I I think one of
the problems that we have is the notion
that a digital currency is something
different than the dollar
80 percent of our currency exists as
notations in an electronic Ledger eighty
percent of all the currency including
the transactions hold on I'm not there
yet okay the estimate the estimate that
I read said that it is a billions of
dollars in Bank fees and Swift fees
to transfer money from the United States
to France or anywhere else you want to
transfer it if you're using Swift if you
don't use Swift you got to use something
else Swift is not a bank and it's not a
transmission effort it is the
replacement for a check all it is it
says take money from this bank account
and put it in that bank account that is
all that it does and they charge money
for that
the countries got together and said we
we're paying billions upon billions of
dollars for that why don't we use
another transmission method and
blockchain came along it has nothing to
do with generating a different currency
it says that we can cut out billions of
dollars in fees if all we do is just use
a blockchain and use the Ledger from a
blockchain that's all that they're
trying to do I get it I got it Indiana
good questions
two questions representative um one
curious who put forth that bill who's
sponsoring that bill that went to
Congress and the second part of my
question is how do you think your bill
would impact
taxation of citizens the IRS doing their
job and organize crime or terrorism in
terms of um in terms of looking at it on
a monetary basis uh thank you for those
questions I I don't recall the name I
don't have the handout right in front of
me because I left the original with the
copy machine but on that handout
identifies the prime sponsor in Congress
of the anti-cbdc bill
um as far as addressing how my bill
would
I really I think the broad part of the
question is how would it affect the
states
relationship to the federal government
when it comes to the federal
government's coinage powers and what
they currently do
and that's a very good question that
needs to be explored because right now
the way it works is at least the way
it's supposed to work if everything is
done correctly is the federal government
only gets access to private information
about sales and things of that nature
that individual citizens are conducting
with a warrant
and such a central bank digital currency
would completely do away with the
necessity to have a warrant before
accessing that sort of information if
it's programmed in a certain way that
this bill is seeking to address so the
answer would be if the federal
government decides that it wants to
introduce essential Bank digital
currency whether it does it through the
government itself through the Federal
Reserve or through some other third
party that it's acting as a quasi-public
private actor
um it wouldn't ultimately make much
difference it would
if they wanted to obtain that
information without a warrant through
cbdc and we blocked the implement the
implementation of that currency within
this state then they would not be able
to have access to that information which
pointedly is precisely what this bill is
trying to accomplish
okay so here's let's just show you guys
all know where I'm coming from on this
issue over the years we would have bills
that we uh there were resolutions
that would urge Congress to pass
something
okay and as some of you might know I
vote I always vote against resolutions
because I don't think they're worth the
paper they're printed on okay because
they don't have any effect Congress is
going to do whatever it wants to do
whether things is right or wrong but the
reason the compelling reason why people
do it is that they want to send the
message they want where we are with
something where we're thinking okay and
the classic example was uh Crow
Dickinson uh was always upset that Maine
would send over uh uh Tax Collectors to
North Conway and see if anybody was
selling refrigerators into Maine okay
and he wanted to to borrow it he wanted
to ban it well we we weren't gonna you
know pass laws to do that but we always
kept his bill alive
and the live is it would send any
message that we are aware of this issue
we have a vehicle that is something were
to occur
we the state could try to do something
not in this case probably if the federal
government actually did pass it which I
guess people want the federal government
to pass something but in some cases if
some you know something different but so
the reason why I recommend interim study
okay and I know this your first term so
just you know right an interim study the
advantage of an inner study you know or
disadvantage is one way to look at it is
the bill is debt
okay the real the bill really is itl but
the committee still has it
so we would get to vote on it one more
time
a year from now
okay and a year from now
we can either say recommend for future
legislation or not recommend for future
legislation
and Anita will back me up last year
every single bill that was interim
studied was itl
we said not recommended for information
but the key element was that we kept it
alive we always allowed the discussion
to occur anybody can come forward and
say oh by the way you know that issue
look what I just saw in the paper you
know look what I see what's going on in
El Salvador who is the one who's got
cryptocurrency as their currency okay
I'm just saying else I mean whoever
people want to make those reference
points okay so yes the bill as it's
written is clearly flawed because it's
making references that it shouldn't have
it could absolutely be in the wrong
section but at the same time interim
study is we're not closing the door that
we will be willing to take more
information
along an issue now I would just remind
you they're going to be some other bills
farther down
you know over in that health insurance
categories okay that it's gonna I'm
gonna recommend the same thing and
that's fine okay the question I have is
this as the bill is written the only
people that get punished
for the feds doing whatever currency
thing this thing seems to think might
happen our New Hampshire residents and
as long as the bill says that that we
alone are going to get punished that we
are forbidden to use that currency
I I can't see keeping this alive you're
I understand you're making a case of why
this bill is is highly flawed and it's
the way it's written
the end of the case is is what was as I
always say every bill has a grained of
Truth
every bill has a grand truth and all I'm
saying is is it really worth it you know
to you know intermediate because again
this is a 10 10 otherwise it's a 10 10
issue again I don't know it is I think
it's you think that's people that
actually want to punish New Hampshire
residents I for some crazy currency
thing that they absolutely think that
this Republicans uh are are are are are
very much concerned
as reading the reading these findings
are very much concerned about what is
going on out there therefore they would
want us to pass something now I know
this is not what we would pass
okay
we're gonna have this conversation go
for it we're gonna have this
conversation multiple times
what I'm just saying is we're not voting
today okay we're not voting today
we're not at this point this is a
subcommittee recommend you know looking
at subcommittee recommendation okay so
uh and this is the business subcommittee
so I don't know who's here from the
business
okay so we got one two three four
five who else is on the business up
getting six okay that sure looks like a
3-3 vote to me
okay
how many more things do you have on here
that you're worried that you're that
you're all lined up again oh my God no I
promise though these are the only two I
care about we've done the two that I
care about I'll be quiet about
everything else okay I promise okay okay
this isn't a 10 10 yet
right at this moment the subcommittee is
not we have no recommendation that's
fine I think that that's
okay you want to take a vote
okay of the subcommittee of the
subcommittee all those who are in favor
of of interim study the motion I will
make is an interim study motion
in room study motion all those in favor
of interim study please raise
okay we have one two three
are you who's on there
yeah where's the list
and then McClure Herbert
okay is that clear nope
okay one two three and Chris do you have
your Hannah four four okay
bye all right okay
the subcommittee recommends interim
study
thank God
wait till 24. no that's fine it's fine
exactly 2024 you can do you know
whoever's in this chair can do what they
think is the radius thing okay uh HB 227
relative Fair access to financial
services so this is another similar
issue
and I'm just recommending thank you very
much I'm recommending to interim study
this bill this bill is not ready for
prime time but we want to send the
message that we definitely don't want to
hear that you know abuse by Financial
incentives and using uh this is this is
the one we did get an amendment
yeah that's right but also now this is
the red line
representative we we also did pass one
of your bills last year
that had the state
that's another kid but I'm saying we the
legislature did
right and this is just trying to go
beyond that
yeah so you turn the mic on okay so or
would you be okay with us uh interim
studying this bill and just keeping this
issue alive so we can talk about it and
specially pay attention to if we find
out that some financial institution
really was
selling it sold to to ESG
I I certainly would be uh
agreeable to that I what was submitted
however was
last uh spring when you reviewed
reviewed the bill there were some
various issues that were raised by uh
opponents of the bill and an amendment
was crafted and you never got a chance
to look at it right so what you have
should have in front of you is that
Amendment from OLX that's excellent
that's great that I really appreciate
having this now okay thank you very much
okay all right does the subcommittee
need to well I I would prefer to have
some discussion on this before we Italy
no we're not in ital we're interim study
even before we do that okay know more
about the bill
well
if knowing about it means if you heard
my Spiel at the beginning here that if
we're going to spend time learning
delving deep into a bill then I'm going
to schedule it for another day
well let's just have a preliminary
discussion about it
I'd like to hear what the gentleman has
to say okay sure
go ahead
turn your mic on make sure thank you uh
what the amendment did uh and you should
have the amendment from OLS and then and
then another copy which gives you the
amended language in Red so it's easy to
see
one of the uh or two of the various uh
opponents of the bill were concerned
that uh the
um the bill would cause them to have to
change the scope of their actions an
agricultural bill or agricultural bank
and a Trust Bank we're concerned that
the bill would make them have to open up
their Bank to
every member of the public so that was
addressed in section A 1A
saying that that's not the case
the bankers Association were concerned
that
um those that were feeling aggrieved by
the process
working with the bank would become
hostile and volatile and and the bankers
could not use uh could not
um
stop the process from going forward
because of the way the bill was written
and and section B amends that language
to basically say that if you have a
client that's becoming hostile and
volatile that is reason for the bank not
dealing with them a legitimate reason so
it takes that issue off the table
um and one of the last things was the
penalty section was inappropriately
cited the wrong RSA was given so that
was fixed
so those those fundamental issues were
changed the key premise of the bill
however remains that there is is a is
potential a problem here there's this is
a forward-looking bill looking at what
people are in the banking industry are
saying they are going to do and when I
say people in the banking industry the
top six banks in the United States say
they are going to implement these kinds
of tactics the chairman of Bank of
America and I'm going to give you the
one takeaway quote here
take our 200 000 people our three
trillion dollar balance sheet are 60
billion of expenses you start aiming
that gun and you take across all these
companies it's huge
so if they're going to implement these
kinds of tactics
you have the senior major banks in the
United States agreeing that implementing
these kinds of tactics is something they
are looking to do they haven't done it
yet if you look at their program first
they look at their Bank themselves
how are we going to operate within ESG
criteria next they look at all their
suppliers and the third step which we're
not at yet is they look at their clients
this bill is forward-looking to say
you're not going to look at your clients
we're going to stop it
got it thank you very much
do we really want to keep going no no
this is a this is such a slight
difference this I just I'd like to ask
the chair going forward that we not
start the conversation by asking the
person testifying wouldn't you agree
that we should interim study this I
would like to have the conversation
first okay if you want me not to try to
move things along that's fine I can I
would not categorize it as moving things
okay
okay the business subcommittees or
anybody here would like to pursue this
bill a little more and have a
subcommittee on it anybody on this
subcommittee okay say none so at this
point
um we're uh
we're gonna treat it as uh that the
subcommittee will was willing to interim
study this bill
would you like a bill okay all those are
the business subcommittee to support
interim study please raise your hand
one two three four
all those opposed
you're okay with your room study sure
okay five and who's at five to one okay
all right moving on I'll spell 645. okay
this is one of those bills that um I was
very much hoping that we would get past
this year
um I know the committee is still working
on it and I can see
the Secretary of State's office here so
um on the 17th
yeah
you be available
of that day
okay uh how about the 18th then
the day after would that be better
say it again
on this on the set
okay
so that is the 17th then right okay 17th
okay okay
I hear Ryan you you guys threw the
curveball who is it
uh the banking Department the bank
Department yeah did we even have anybody
in the bank Department here okay you
guys threw a curveball on this one
okay
uh hopefully these things can be
resolved right
okay
okay all right so that'll be on the 17th
then is that the October 17th that's
October 17th okay
okay
all right
next up is uh relative enforcement of
condom condominium liens for assessment
HB 178.
uh I think I did get a letter
uh email is anybody here
I mean I I my my notes is it's uh We've
this committee has killed this bill
many times we did pass it at one point
in time with the uh uh the six months uh
because that was the Fannie Mae and uh
so my note I have it is is an itl
is there anybody feel that want to
discuss it rather than it yelling it
they're seeing none all those in favor
of igl and South Korea Business
committee itla okay one two three four
all right six okay
all right
um relative to the condominium
disclosure or financial information
um I have this also is itl
uh anybody
uh it's 239
anybody wants to go to carpet on that it
all in this one
okay question I have a question yes is
the are these two bills uh 178 and
uh 239 are they uh together no they're
not related not related the um
yeah the the 178 is about putting it
have letting tenants to throw uh uh uh
put liens on on their neighbors uh I
think was what that was the Killer
Killer part of that one and uh 239 is uh
just the financial trying to get
financial informations out of out of
these uh boards and and I think there
was even a bond issue in there or
something but I don't know it was it was
it was pretty much unenforceable and it
was problematic for condos okay so itl
with that one
uh that was representative alamy's bill
is it yeah do you want to really okay
all right all right all those in favor
of it yelling please raise your hand one
two three four six okay
next up is uh establishing a study
committee on Resident owned manufactured
housing Park disputes and oversights
okay
um I I have recommend an inexperience to
legislate we already we had passed
something last session I thought we had
you know we had resolved the issues but
um that they're just this putt it just
continues to get stirred yes I I would
recommend the interim interim study on
this as well I think we we've had these
people before us uh over a couple of
times I think the the bill on the other
side I think they that was almost
unanimously passed and I think we should
take up a study of this I I really think
we owe it to these people
um I'm not opposed to that that's fine
because it's really killing a bill when
you interim study ability bill but it
means you're we are concerned about an
issue that we would like to keep it
around to discuss it
okay everybody in favor of interim study
I'll make sure I got the right list can
you read that list again
uh yes for business banking yes the
business banking
spear okay so we got Aaron Cole action
oh yeah and you're missing a Democrat so
you're replacing that Democrat did you
approve that chair
you're both okay so stop voting
you're not on it
yeah
oh okay so this
this list is wrong then no no that's
right
I had I thought I printed the official
list and send it out on this let's take
a photo this email but on this didn't I
was in her page two in this email that I
I just didn't print
so um it was on 115 for the 115 but it
wasn't on the 10 a.m
what's that
the list of people who are on the
insurance
oh I see the list yeah the list at the
bottom here I'm not unassure
I don't know according to it so that's
who I have for your banking
that's from the very beginning yeah this
is
yeah no this is Insurance that's
insurance so where's the afternoon oh
that one didn't happen didn't have it
okay I'm not going to worry about it too
much because if the motion is interim
study all those in favor raise your hand
and
okay overwhelmingly supportive it okay
all right on to my next category
uh 73 right to uh repair of Home
Appliances
so this bill started out to be it was
all about big appliances and now all of
a sudden you know they come in with
little appliances that frankly are I
don't even think you need the manual for
because you're just going to throw it
out and get another one but
I do have a I have a very expensive gas
stove and I probably wouldn't throw out
but I don't know how how complicated it
is to repair it but
so okay I I I was not uh too excited
about passing it says him when he want
to Pat Uh keep this bill around in room
study it or talk about it some more or
do we
you have something you want to say Keith
yeah just quickly um so I think this is
going to be one of those perennial
issues until it gets resolved so
I guess interim study if we want to
follow the same philosophy of keeping an
issue alive uh just because we know it's
going to come back again okay
I'm fine with that
okay interim study all those in favor of
interim study please raise your hand
okay all the pose
good enough okay
all right next up
is prohibiting the state from
Contracting the Chinese government or
Affiliated technology manufacturers
okay so I was going to interim study
this because people were worried about
it but I don't know
yeah I was worried that uh the the
governor did say that that the
um the state
was prohibiting so I wasn't really sure
what the governor's order begins or ends
or this goes a little farther than the
governor's order
okay question yes didn't think I read
the governor's order at one point and it
seemed to say that
the state for state-owned computers
correct they would not buy from the
Chinese
and as a matter of fact the federal
government doesn't allow any of the
federal agencies to buy from the Chinese
but private people I don't know that
anything says that you can't do that
well I hope not because everybody's
computer is made in China
that let alone be confusing which China
so I don't know what this bill does so
I'm not clear on what this bill does
okay so you want to kill it or enter
study it
Jesus we already got it yeah I was going
to understudy it just just just just to
send the message that we we care but we
don't want to clutter up our statutes
with China so all those in favor of
interim study please say raise your hand
we got
one
okay
to hold up somebody okay let's go
but you don't know what you're holding
up okay
okay
yeah uh House Bill 173 related to toilet
facilities provided by restaurants uh I
think we wanted to repeal the statue
right
okay so so we we need to drop an
amendment to repeal it and can you I
know that you had some other yeah why
don't you come on up introduce yourself
and we're going to ask you to do a
homework assignment
good morning
good morning Phil Sherman chair of the
building code review board uh the
amendment that I found on the website
already
deletes one of the Clauses okay we speak
in favor of that
as I testified I think to the
subcommittee getting rid of the whole
thing would be even better but I'm not
going to fall in my sword on that one I
do think that the separate fixture issue
I'll refer to it as all gender
that train has left the station so the
plumbing and the building codes already
address
um I'll call it the current thinking on
that the upcoming building code will
permit uh what I'll refer to as the
European style of one big room with a
bunch of stalls and sinks in the middle
or whatever to be used by everybody the
current codes sometimes it's referred to
as a Dunkin Donuts Amendment basically
if you have two unisex rooms they must
be posted for use by everybody you can't
can't assign them so this conflicts with
the code I think it's a might out of
date
RSA 155 seems to be the closet of of
Public Safety stuff and once in a while
I have to clean the closet out so
probably not the best
simile
okay so but if if you had your drugs we
should just uh repeal the whole
paragraph
because you know I love repeal I love
that word the rest of this section uh
gives the
DHHS the right to
provide relief but they've still got to
get really from the building code
so it's it's really dealt with through
the codes at this point the only thing
this does do is it brings in alcoholic
beverage service the building code
separates between restaurants and what
they call taverns or bars so clearly
there's restaurants with alcohol without
alcohol not clear that that really ought
to lead us to a different approach to
Plumbing fixtures at this point
but we wouldn't have any problem with
deleting the whole section
okay he's talking about so this would be
155 colon 4 Roman numeral one
I believe it's colon 40 isn't it excuse
me I said 40 40. Roman number one that's
correct just repeal that
okay
who wants to do that Amendment anybody
okay you want to take care of that you
get that Amendment drawn up okay great
so you just just go to legislative
Services the old men it'll be Amendment
to the bill
and it'll be just to remove
it would actually would be uh it would
it would change the whole bill it would
be uh
amend the entire bill after the entitle
thank you
so he doesn't he's telling you right I'm
telling you right now what it's going to
be so I'm yeah so so I'll talk we'll
talk afterwards so but every what it'll
be is it'll say
um
I meant replace everything after the
enacting clause
and then it's going to say repeal RSA
155 colon 40 Roman numeral one
and then it'll have
the and the effective date will stay the
same
very simple just love that piece of cake
one year I passed I peeled with one bill
I had two whole rsas repealed we are
saving the state of New Hampshire
that's the Pinnacle of my repeal
statutes okay all right thank you very
much
so that would be odd to pass as amended
all those in the subcommittee agreed to
that please raise your hand
this is the business everything's
business to this morning you're not on
business
uh
okay all right I'm sorry all right good
you're on all right you're on today no
matter what okay all those in favor of
repealing of of uh the lot to pass as
amended please raise your hand okay one
two three four five six
all those who opposed to not to pass
this amendment saying none okay
unanimously
okay
all right uh okay now we're to
Senate Bill 201 relative to resale of
event tickets
so as we all know this is not a problem
just to eventic it's it's uh hotels
and um
another other what other
vacation rentals I think that you can
take you can sometimes choose the wrong
booking company 201
yes in line with your idea that if the
bill is not enforceable we probably
should I TL it this one is an itl okay
perfect
okay yes any discussion on the motion
yes representative not enforceable is
that the concern it's not important it's
totally unenforceable okay
I mean yeah you're yeah you're gonna go
chase the internet you know companies
that that are based out of China or
whoever they are I'm trying to remember
the discussion this is this is the one
where I know I remember the bill I'm
talking about the enforcement discussion
wasn't it was going to be under the AG's
office or something uh it was a
violation of the consumer protection act
and under the consumer protection act uh
and you know it's the Attorney General's
or the consumer protection division
and I believe he's he was here but I
don't see him today
and he the enforcement was is you know
he everybody's aware of this problem and
like I say it happens more with hotels
I mean the you know bookings
my wife did it uh this this past year
and then she she started telling the
story and the person
and never said oh by the way that you
know you're you're not talking to the
hotel you're talking to this a booking
company
and uh and then of course because we
were intimately found out what happened
by the time when we checked in and then
the instructions were lost
didn't get through so
but the ticket this this ticket scalping
you know it's a detectively it's not
scalping but how it was outrageous to
hear that
um they they promised something and they
they might not even have that ticket and
then they go then they call up and and
buy the ticket through the actual
through Ticketmaster and then turn
around and sell it to you for a fee
and they and they in in your purchasing
with them you pre you agree to a
purchasing fee Without Really realizing
that's that's what you did wasn't part
of it like a disclosure to like you have
to disclose that you're not buying it
wasn't that the point of this build
mainly was like if you're on
Ticketmaster you say hey this is not
being bought directly from whatever
browse theater or something like that
right exactly
I mean that and then there's the other
part which is you have to own it
outright to be able to sell it but you
could you actually had to have it in
possession right right so how do you
enforce that that's the part that's hard
to what were the other parts the other
part enforceable because then you can
just make sure that it's disclosed
somewhere right
um
director of The Palace Theater
um has
um indicated on the website that if you
don't buy that you should buy the ticket
at The Palace Theater website so they
can do that so the companies can you
know assure individuals that if they buy
that ticket with them where the events
no I understand I was just saying like I
think
and it might be hard to enforce because
we're a small state but like yeah this
would require like StubHub to to have a
thing saying you're not buying it from
the past how do we how do we mandate
that yeah how do we bend it you can
notify
right
so by the end I I mean I mean it's this
is one of those classic cases I wish we
could help inform
the general public and you know in the
old days if Google it used to admit that
you got to look for the line but now the
line is so thin you can barely see it
it's like it's a dotted line and that so
when you look at a listing above the
above front is the advertisers
and then just under you'll see just a
little little dots and under that is
actually the actual entity that you were
seeking you would even if you typed in
Palace Theater however I have now found
for myself personally that and and it's
and it's in and I'm so far I'm betting a
hundred percent that when you type in
Palace Theater
over in the right
is the map
is the mapping is Google Maps and if you
click on the Google Maps it will then
pull up and say would you like the web
page and that has worked for me a
hundred percent
so if I could if I could tell anybody in
the room if you're Googling if you want
to make sure you're getting the actual
people you're trying to deal with
actually go look at the Google Map and
click on the icon in the Google Map now
having said that it's amazing how many
times I've done that and I look on it
and it says do you own this site that
means the actual owners the actual
business doesn't even realize it's there
and that happened to me years ago
several years ago and immediately
because someone someone had put on my
property and wrote it not what I I call
it Sunrise Castle they put it up as hunt
castle and I immediately said oh yeah I
own that
oh you know and and uh and then took it
over and made sure that nobody else
could then post you know
post up to it but so all right but
it's unbelievable you take a picture
you take a picture and if and and make a
comment this is a great you know runner
runner ever Google will then ask you and
I say you know can we identify can we
identify that location people do this
all on their phone
you could you could you sorry
that's right right but yeah that you can
you're online so yeah it's ironically
then you can then identify a location
and best of all they even give you a a
web listing you can get a web listing
for free
whoever heard Google gave anything away
for free but yes there's a nice view I
think one of the things that I saw in
heard during that discussion and one of
the worst things was there's this big
company in the UK
that routinely
um commandeers websites for these kinds
of things and I tried to book a
a thing over in uh what is it in Nashua
at the at the art center and that site
did did that and charged like three
times the amount of what the ticket was
when I was trying to go to the Nashua
Arts Center your site
and I there's no way to to legislate
against something happening in the UK
and we were told that they were
constantly under lawsuits and they don't
care they're just a factor of business
okay all those in favor of interim study
right is that where we're at interim
study or itl
itl okay all those in favor of itl raise
your hand
one two three four five okay okay
uh itl
all right we're almost there
but believe it or not okay uh all right
legalizing cannabis for retail sales
interim study
um uh the the commission is meeting
they're moving right along
um
I'm on the commission
and uh it's uh it's a very Lively
discussion because uh they're all the
all the potential opposition is also on
the commission so we have the chief of
police and we have uh but the ACLU is
right and actually represent field is on
it and represented Sullivan's on it so
Commerce is well represented on this
Commission
so
um and I'm fully confident that that we
will come up with legislation in the end
but we'll keep this one alive just to
have it around
okay all those in favor of interim study
two three
no but if yeah
okay
all right all right it could be liquor
you want to be liquor
my name is not anywhere today so yeah
because I didn't because you're just
liquor right because we the one liquor
bill we have 279 the department is still
working on on their Amendment but
you're right it was I I that was my that
was a mistake on my partner
who's here from liquor so John's here
Lil's here Lily excuse me thank you
don't you sign Lil on your on your
remember my name is Lily okay I I don't
know why I don't know why I had little
in my head Lily
okay John and represent bilio and
representative Burroughs and
representative Sullivan okay
um all those in favor of interim study
raise your hand
um the legalizing cannabis for retail
sales five five forty four okay
and all those opposed
fair enough okay five to one
five to one
interim study okay
and last but not least Senate Bill 180
relative to product labeling and
prohibition of the sale of hemp products
containing THC
so
[Music]
um
Delta Delta nine yes
I mean it's a serious
ly yeah right so what addressed some of
them this one got overcome didn't it by
611. so what happened what what happened
in the end that the the bill that passed
the study committee the commission
included this uh ban a Delta 9 but
it has a caveat that it's sun sets
so uh and and I'll take responsibility
for that because I wanted to put the
pressure on getting the commission bill
passed
so one of the ideas of having that we
will deal with the Delta 9 Delta a Delta
9 issue in
in that legislation so that's why Sunset
it so for all intents and purposes you
know we can just uh interim study this
just to keep it alive well so what
happens if the bill doesn't if we don't
get something passed or signed this year
so if something didn't happen when we
meet a year from now
when does it sunset the sunset is is uh
July 1 of 2024.
so
isn't this 2023 yeah July 1 2024 so six
months
well it'd be six months not six months
it was six months the effective date was
the beginning of the year so the the um
that so a year from now let's say if it
didn't happen
you know if it didn't get passed then we
we can then recommend for future
legislation
if we still want to be in it but I'm not
sure the committee was fully I think we
were all concerned that there was no age
requirement if I recall the conversation
requirements
and the the labeling and I would say
that it you know the commission where we
talked about packaging
the problem with the Delta Packaging is
it it is appealing to kids right
and and that's clearly a problem yeah I
mean but if we're gonna I guess I'd just
be concerned that if we're going to
struggle to get cannabis legalized which
we've been struggling with various
different models we wouldn't want to
like throw the baby out with a bath
water not have something like this go
through which would actually make a real
difference for potentially a young child
buying these things that are completely
unregulated and it sounds like when
there's somebody who actually gets like
poisoning from THC it's generally this
synthetic THC not the stuff you get from
marijuana so but I think
I think we shouldn't I don't know I
don't know the best way to deal with it
I don't know if we want to work on it
because when we talked about it before I
raised a question about I'm not really
supportive of initially Banning it but
like putting an age restriction on it
right now there is none I almost wonder
if we just tweaked it to add data
description versus not right band and
then passed it so that's true we could
fix it by age restriction and packaging
requirements I wonder if that might be a
useful thing problem with that is the
packaging requirements then is going to
who what state entity is then going to
be regulating the packaging and and so
therefore the packet because you had the
packaging means you they have to submit
it to a a state entity which in this
case when we're done with the commission
will be the Liquor Commission right okay
the liquid commission will have a set up
a division within the marijuana board
that would be approving packaging that
that is not child child interesting
so we are now gonna if we were to try to
pass that now
it's before that entity has even been
created so it's somewhat problematic to
try to do that now
could you still do the age requirements
requirement revisit the packaging I mean
at least at least then I doubt that
there's a lot of people buying it around
your age but I'm sure there are some and
so this would at least maybe eliminate
right so yeah can you pull up the bill
um so we could just
um
remember that also the bill needed
Amendment but it was about the 0.03 or
something of THC it was ahead had
decimal it had a decimal point problem
so it's
is this liquor yeah
just say what it is okay that's right
all right so retail approaches
Association yeah so it had the 0.03
rather than certain points yeah there
was a
[Music]
it was allowing the atcs to sell it
which is fine the eight that's right
because it was that's right Simon was
involved in the assignment he was yeah
he was
he was he was ensuring that he was
ensuring that only he could sell it
right rather than than the store is
selling it which would take care of the
21 year old problem because he had to be
21 to get into an ATC
that's why he doesn't say anything about
that it's an ATC program
yes representative uh when we last left
that bill we corrected the value of uh
hemp
but we did not correct the direction
in other words it's the way it was last
left it's legislating against hemp over
Point greater than 0.03 and hemp is not
greater than 0.03 it's less than it
should be less than greater than is pot
and cannabis
right so you got to change
to less than not greater than because
then you're stepping on marijuana
and that's not the definition of hemp
I
just hit her up say it I mean you want
to work on this element you want to you
want to take charge of this it sounds
and we did this amendment and it sounds
like we just we just changed to less
than so what is the complicate what's
what why are we so right now right now
it doesn't have anything to do about the
21. right okay because the 21
is is because it says it can only be
sold through
the it's medical marijuana people
um
right Joey
we're looking at Senate Bill 180 as
amended by the Senate
okay
yeah
was that going to get repealed in six
months or
yesterday
right okay no that's fine that's right
because I I knew that we addressed it in
611. yeah I think
okay okay
so right now so right now it it did was
it a 21
.
age there's no age requirement and no
and no atcs they just just took that
just lifted just that paragraph and did
the less less than it's him yeah so okay
yeah so it's happy if there's too much
THC in them then you know it's you get
nucleus problems okay so that's why
greater than is correct and
representative
it's talking about the level of THC in
hemp right so right it's defined as less
than 0.03 that's the definition of hemp
well so the prohibition is against
anything greater than 0.3 that's what
the prohibition is you can't sell any
hemp that has THC that's greater
but that's not hemp I'm sorry that's not
him if it's greater than 0.03 it's not
him it's synthetic right so well the key
elements is somebody might call it him
yeah
if you're saying that or someone might
call it him but it's and in your mind
it's not hemp it's marijuana and this
statute says you're that that is correct
if if
okay
if you're calling it you know THC and if
it's greater than 0.3 then it ain't hemp
right it's illegal
okay so that's in effect until until the
end of the
right
so all right so theoretically
theoretically if we interim study it
then
like we get here a year from now and
let's say nothing passed through the
marijuana
that would have expired so yes we would
then probably would want that
legislation we would actually do move a
year from now as recommend for future
legislation so I would say we should
interim study that
okay
yes I just want to make my notes here
all right all those on the Merrell
liquor committee
all those on the liquor committee agree
agree with interim study please raise
your hand one two three four five
okay and those opposed
I'm still lost on the 0.03 versus 0.3
yes the 0.03 is wrong it is now it's 0.3
okay
all right so you're okay with that now
unanimous perfect okay
unbelievable huh
okay so what I have for my notes just to
summarize is
um on the 17th of October we will be uh
focusing in on House Bill 645 the
decentralized autonomous organizations
and uh the pfas
and legislation
[Music]
and that's actually two of them but I
think one of them will end up
interim studying it once we're once we
find one that we can agree on with a new
solution
okay
thank you all very much and we'll do
this again
at 1 1 15.
just insurance
yes
and I broke it up into I broke it up
into insurance and then Property and
Casualty but very close
yeah no it's all pretty much health
insurance I don't think we had too many
products yeah it's all health
you're not doing anything
we'll get started here
um the room looks a little lighter than
this morning
but I guess that's because this issue is
a little more narrow
all right
um so somewhat picking up where we left
off House Bill 414 related to health
insurance coverage for preventative pfas
carrier
anybody wanna
run with this bill
uh
yes
okay
so you're not on this committee but I
did see the Committees are well posted
inside
all right
okay
representative purcelli
hey do you want to make the motion
no how about representative okay
representative
uh second by representative hunt moves
in expedient to legislating discussion
on the motion
okay this is the subcommittee which is
Terry post purcelli and Calabro Vincent
Gibbs and Burroughs
so that means you're missing two people
okay
and now you're now you're back in okay
okay the Motions didn't explain to
legislating discussion on the motion
scene done all those in favor raise
their hand
s yeah yeah okay motion carries
eight
one two three four five six seven eight
yep
okay uh establishing Committee just
studying all pairs system of insurance
for Hospital services
representative Rose we want to
overwhelmingly passes no I'm sorry
I knew you were toying with me
[Laughter]
okay represented Pro second by
representative hunt moving experience to
legislate any discussion on the motion
scene on all those in favor please say
aye
aye that was opposed so moving and
obviously
okay uh 353 establishing an interstate
compact for Universal Health Care
uh we did get him
right see okay uh representative
collabro second by representative Burris
move Scenic speed to legislate any
discussion on the motion
see none all those in favor please say
aye aye I suppose
okay uh House Bill 373 relative to
billing for ambulance Services
representative Burroughs
um I was gonna ask for itl because of
the um commission ongoing but I was
asked by representative Stringham if we
could
um if we could do interim study because
he thought there might be one or two
elements in the bill that would
complement what the commissioner is
doing
and I personally don't have a problem
with that
okay
dream study
everybody okay with interim study
all right uh all those in favor say aye
aye aye those opposed
to move unanimously
all right next is relative to prompt
payments for managed care
I'm interested how that's going Mr
commissioner
this is official
to get sworn in this morning too they're
not swearing in
I would only just comment that uh I have
great respect and admiration for New
Hampshire's unique form of democracy but
that Council process certainly has its
harrowing moments it does it's a it's a
roller coaster ride in it it certainly
is it certainly is so the update is that
in about two weeks time three weeks time
we will have a comprehensive
presentation ready for you
to give you a sneak peek of what you
might expect I've kind of envisioned
that this will
have three parts to to it uh the
presentation will the first part will
lay out the numbers as it pertains to a
very narrowly tailored definition of
prompt pay
and what you're going to find is based
off of the MCAS data
that if you're just looking at again
that narrow definition of 30 days
you're going to see the New Hampshire
carriers are almost 97 percent in
compliance which is right in line with
the national average we're actually
slightly better than the national
average
but at the same time we obviously know
that there are some issues that we've
got to deal with
and so what it demonstrates to us is
that if you're looking at the issue
purely within prompt pay 30 days you're
not getting at the heart of what has
been at issue with carriers and the
hospitals and so there has to be
something more to the problem and so we
intend to identify some of those issues
share with you what they are
and then perhaps provide some
recommendations for you all to consider
certainly our team to think about and
consider I know that all of you want to
resolve these issues we want to resolve
these issues I've made a commitment to
the executive Council to do everything
that I can to help bring this to
resolution and that's what we will do
and then we will take a look at the
report that the New Hampshire Hospital
Association put forward and again we'll
do a deep dive analysis of that and I
think that all three of those pieces
will complement each other very very
well and will give you a clear and
comprehensive picture as to what's
what's really going on
so that's my update as it pertains to
that legislation and when did you expect
this to two three weeks that would mean
you tell us if you want to come back and
you know whatever works for your
schedule like I said I think we'll be
ready to roll in about two weeks time
okay 17th it is perfect
okay
all right any questions for any comments
all right okay
um
tenant Bill 235
my understanding you guys are still
negotiating sorry
DJ
yeah 235 the uh
Behavioral Health people you guys are
still negotiating is there still
that process is still negotiating
number of meetings
um with really interested parties this
is a mental health uh yeah the mental
health yeah
um and we've identified
um
a number of billing codes that are
relevant to this issue and
um we have another meeting set up to try
to get final confirmation
that those billing codes are
the ones that are you know not being
successfully build
um and once we do that we'll be able
we'll be in a position to basically
solve the problem
okay
so while you're there I know there's
another one
um how's your the study committee on
coverage for Reproductive Health Care
you guys were doing a study committee on
that was our 198 which we had ours was
the uh
you want to give us an update on that
while you're there
so the report it has been concluded it's
been done we used our contractor to do
it I believe it's been distributed to
the stakeholders
this point
we'll make be sure to get a copy to you
as well well I don't have that one I'm
not a mistakeholder but hey I don't
think I ever seen it yet so we will get
that to you ASAP it was just concluded I
think late last week okay uh it was just
concluded late last week can you give us
the highlights what was the sure
I was in Scotland
the number is big
that's what I can tell you the number is
big it is Big it's big yeah well some
some of us had predicted when that got
passed that it would be big yes
representative spear
it's not exactly a question but it is a
a comment based on some research I did
over the summer on this bill it's we're
talking about the reproductive Health
Care One
okay
no state in this country has such a bill
has such a law that is true
five countries in the world have the law
and the only that's with some extent and
those countries have all got
um Universal Health Care kind of things
government-sponsored Health Care
it
I'm not sure that we should even
consider it based on that kind of a
thing no I I will get to that but I just
want to hear how the department so the
only other question did it have because
you also have the you know because you
have all the secret formula stuff here
so one of the numbers we've always been
this committee's always been intrigued
by is what percentage of quote unquote
mandates have on our overall premium and
I know that that does create a judgment
call of what the premiums and then we've
we've heard you know anywhere from three
to three to eight or something on there
we've heard numbers
um do we have an idea what percentage
this had impact it had on
I don't know how much of the impact this
specific would have right I mean I think
as you appreciate chairman hunt
rarely is it the case now this is an
exception to that but rarely is it the
case that any single mandate is going to
significantly put upward pressure on
premium the problem is of course the
cumulative effect of all of them and
what does that introduce into the
dynamic such that it could put upward
pressure on premiums
my understanding from my team as it
pertains to this piece of legislation is
that they faced a really difficult
barrier in terms of how the legislation
was drafted
and so what I would I say this all the
time but is a general rule but in this
case
we're happy to be a resource to anyone
who would like us to review
legislation to ensure that it is
achieving the objective that you as
policy makers are hoping to to achieve
sometimes it's difficult when folks get
results back from us
um they're not happy with the results
that came back out we can only assess
the legislation based off of what's
there on the paper in terms of what
would become statute if it were to
become law
uh and so there were there were some
drafting issues Freeman I think did the
best they could
to assess it based off of how it was
drafted and so I will be sure to get the
the study to you before the end of the
day okay
sure you're telling me I have to have
another mandate to do a baseline to
compare this one we have some
information that we can we can make
available to you know on the on the
global question that'd be great
um if I might Mr chairman I'd update the
committee on one other item as it
pertains to a ground ambulance which I
know is a topic okay yeah yeah that's
true yeah that'd be good so as
representative Burroughs knows and I
believe I made you aware of this too
representative hunt the New Hampshire
insurance department is trying to take a
proactive approach to resolving a
developing situation it's been
developing for some time but it's really
I think coming to a bit of a crisis
Point as it pertains to ground ambulance
providers particularly the private
ground ambulance providers at the end of
the day the municipals are under the
same pressure but they have safety nets
underneath them the safety nets being
other areas of their communities fire
department budget or ultimately all of
us as property taxpayers to our
communities but the privates of course
do not have that safety net and so I
have convened what I've called an
ambulance Summit for lack of a better
term but I've brought together some
stakeholders from the ambulance provider
Community uh led by uh state senator
Susan Prentice she's kind of identified
some of the key players there at the
table all of the commercial carriers are
at the table we have had some very
positive discussions so far
we have had the group break into I think
three or four subgroups that are looking
at different aspects of this uh and and
I think we're going to hopefully make
some progress I'm not entirely sure that
we'll need any sort of legislation to
address this which is good news
obviously but it is possible
and I want to stress possible
though I am an optimist that there may
be an agreement around
some form of limited prohibition on
balance billing as it pertains to ground
ambulance that both sides through that
give and take process may be able to
reach an agreement
and so that be the case
um where representative Burroughs bill
is in interim study I assume that it is
still viable to potentially become a
vehicle toward an agreement uh before
you've got to get things out uh I think
your deadline is the beginning of
November yeah well at the end of the day
we could have it till the first week of
January okay because the first week of
January we could then come in with a
different motion if that was an
amendment great well as I said I am an
optimist but I'm not making any promises
as most of you know this has been a many
decades-long issue but I think that
given the Confluence of events facing
the situation here in New Hampshire with
ambulances it may be the opportune
moment for some sort of a grand a
compromise in a package of things that
will hopefully resolve the issue
great thank you thank you very much
okay now to the last one uh excuse me Mr
chairman yep so are we deferring to 35
and 198 to a later date two yes uh yeah
235 uh which we just discussed yes we
will we will uh I guess we'll take him
up on the 17th
foreign so we have three bills date
specific now for the 17th okay now four
now we have yet no not this afternoon
the 17th two from this morning you are
here well I mean this subcommittee yeah
yeah thank you
okay
all right uh HP 130 repealing the drug
affordability board
I'd like to move itl because apparently
um there's been progress made
um in the budget and and other ways of
dealing with it there was
it was
that is true okay
any discussion on inexpensive legislate
in HP 130
see none all those in favor say aye aye
aye those opposed
Moody Ansley
okay
uh
I think it's the same situation for 172.
so
um
right right so we can ID all that one
also
okay all those in favor of inexpensive
legislate say aye aye those opposed
removed unanimously
okay 303.
so representative Calabro wants to give
life to this bill
um how how many different mandates are
in or entities change the words for that
and I'm going to have the sponsor of the
bill give us a reworded version of this
as we had discussed at our last
committee meeting okay but can you give
me a thumbnail of how many
of the you have
303 somehow it seemed like you threw the
kitchen sink at it he really did which
is why we need more time so I know but I
just want to know
so for the rest of the committee members
um many years ago
can't even remember
uh we had a bill to mandate a natural
pass to be
primary care physicians
and uh and natural paths are what could
be close to into the same categories as
these people and
um the end result was that uh the this
committee said okay
we'll instead of having shall
we turn it into a May
which means that doesn't mandate the
insurance companies to do it
it just means that they're that they're
there there is a parameters that they
could do it and what the parameters
would be if they did want to do it
and
um I have not heard too much pushback on
the natural pass May haven't heard much
any complain about it so I would speak a
little bit about what I know the
sponsors
um were willing to concede about
um and what I've discussed with some
members here in Commerce that um
had originally wanted it to be tabled
the um are retained
essentially we have
um
a system where a primary care provider
like myself has a patient in chronic
pain they generally on average have
about 10 years of chronic pain before
they make any progress in getting the
treatment and getting efficacy
in the short period of time that I've
been a part of hb66 committee which
studies The Chronic the treatment for
non-pharmaceutical treatment of chronic
pain
it's become very clear that most of the
models that we see I'm not as fond of
I'm hoping we can find a better model
but essentially what I know Nagel and
Merchant were willing to concede was
they agreed that it needs to be licensed
by the state a
B we need to make sure that it has a
limit we need to cap what is acceptable
and 12 seem to be the magic number that
insurance companies were happy with
and the third part
was what I told him was that a mandate
isn't going to get past anybody and I
don't want to mandate anything
it's enough of evidence for the research
that we've done thus far that is showing
that this is a more economical solution
and if it's six weeks of efficacy and
less than one and a half epidural
injections I think we should be
evaluating it which we're doing in this
committee
not this committee but that committee
I want to at least get the ball rolling
so that providers like myself have a
little more options than just
Orthopedics neural in a pain clinic
so things like aquatic therapy and yoga
okay
oh I like that's good good okay I want
this done safely and not with just
somebody who says I'm a health care
provider okay sorry licensing is
important
great
okay
so um I urge you guys to get that
Amendment drawn up right away and get it
out to the Committee Member so we can
see it ahead of time
and so at least we can get it and if
there's any questions we could smooth it
so by the time we get to the to the 17th
we can have it resolved
okay
uh
everybody ready to move on from that one
okay 383 relative provider contract
centers for pbms
if everybody understand now what a PBM
is that it's just an offshoot of the
insurance company and
the idea of Licensing and regulating
them and
yes representative spear
so I looked this one up
and six states have exactly the same
words
that this bill has
and on the surface it seems like a good
idea
accept that and every other state that
has this there's a lot of other laws
around it that say things like mac
prices have to be published
the sources for the drugs have to be
available and noticed
they don't have it with this bill the
wording of this bill by itself it needs
to have the other stuff that goes around
it
if we're not going to do that
then this bill kind of leaves us with a
situation where the drug companies or
the I'm not I don't mean the drug
companies the pbms can say well then in
that case we're just going to raise the
price to whatever you can get it for
so
I don't think we should leave the bill
is not viable by itself to do us any
good at all so I'm kind of thinking
maybe we better not do it
so what other states for doing it
uh would you repeat that question what
other states you said had oh Ohio uh had
this laundry list of uh I have a list I
do want me to get I'm interested in any
of them in New England
remember
let me get my notes out
and I write everything down so I've got
it
curious as to why you're you're asking
about New England a week special or um
I I know we do tend to think of
ourselves as being the most highly
regarded region in the country but I
wondered what under it was on the line
here but uh because the same carriers
same carriers thank you
not everyone might have known that New
York California Kentucky Ohio Hawaii and
Illinois and then I went fell asleep and
I didn't go any further
but I thought that was a nice
cross-section of states that did it
all right you're all right itl yeah
everybody okay with itl yeah
okay
all those in favor Innings being
legislate raise your hand
all those opposed okay
I guess I'll make my daughter's soccer
game after all okay granddaughters all
right relative to affordability and
safety of clinically administered drugs
Bill and uh we had a little conversation
and
um at this point
um
the issue is great that to really get us
all informed to knowing about what this
is what's going on out there
um but at this point uh my radical idea
was maybe a little too radical and
people weren't exactly ready for it and
uh so
um yeah I think I would like to interim
study this just so we keep the that
relationship uh balanced in terms of how
uh what the hospitals are charging
um for these uh these
rare and unique books what was your
um that that they had basically had to
use pbms
use the PBF pricing rather than their
in-house pricing the proprietary nature
of that seems to be the big sticking
point
so
is everybody okay with interim study
about 513 for 5 13. yeah
okay all those in favor say aye those
opposed
so moved unanimously
uh last but not least uh directing the
insurance department to conduct a
custody of providing coverage for
Reproductive health care
and we have decided to do that one
10 17. well actually
yeah right
um
right okay
all right
I thought there was two different ones I
thought the the issue
the issue I forgot that it was it was
the cost study involved in it
uh
right okay
but
at this point we're we're we we put it
off to the 17th to actually get
the study so that but it would be a
little premature for us to kill this
building until we until he actually seen
the study but but yes representative two
points
no insurance company is prohibited from
doing it for instance if you want to
work for uh what is it the coffee
company
um Starbucks they offer it nobody's
prohibited from doing it
where the problem comes in in my mind is
forgetting about the cost for a minute
New Hampshire has some of the best uh
fertility or infertility Insurance in
the country they're among the 15 best
states in the country for for
infertility
if we do something like this
and one of the things that says in our
laws is that we cannot provide any
insurance
and this is health insurance by the way
any insurance to a heterosexual couple
that cannot be provided to a same-sex
couple it has to be the same
but they limit it to medical insurance
not social insurance
if a heterosexual couple
wants to go the route that would result
from this being enacted that would mean
that anybody
could then go
and say well I don't want to have sex
with my partner
so I want the insurance if they're going
to make it equal so I want the insurance
company to pay for
the various uh procedures that can be
done you know uh
in vitro fertilization all that kind of
stuff if we're going to make it equal
then everybody can say well I think my
husband is an ugly and I don't want
anything to do with them so I'm gonna go
and do it
but I think
and you can cancel that out
but that but it but it really gets down
to that if we make this equal where do
you draw the line
okay we're not debating this bill right
now I understand and we we absolutely
hear where you're coming from
as I remind everyone everything is now
on YouTube
Forever
I'm so old at this point forever is only
a little ways away
[Music]
all right okay
right on that note okay
all right so what I have is that that we
everybody gets a
um
four day four week vacation from this
committee
so we all come back on the 17th
and
um
and just so you know what that does
because I that following week I will be
uh in Europe so that would mean uh okay
so we have two two e seventh in the 14
yeah we definitely have two weeks after
that into into November uh to uh take
you know have the committee exec all
these bills
um I want I would want to say is that um
the actions that the subcommittees did
today
um
is is is obviously not cast in stone yet
because the committee is not voted on it
so in anyone if there's if there's a
conversation or something and someone
feels you know one way the other
um you know where it's obviously free
free to be rediscussed
at when we exec it but that I'm
obviously I hope that when we get to the
exact session it'll be another one of
our wonderful
uh moving in move it out and get her
done uh exact session so at this point
we have one
two three four five bills for the 17th
and then oh the excuse me uh we do have
uh some liquor bill one little liquor
bill and we are waiting for the
Department to
um
to work it that out in terms of
um and I know that there has been some
discussion around
um
in terms of the over serving you know
that it you know that with it you know
the
um
in terms of like uh the seventh you know
where you get this the days 10 days 30
days you know first first suspension
second best the the underlying theme of
course is that the Liquor Commission
definitely pursues every case
uh and and so that that there was some
conversation we want give them an up to
so that it's the severity of the case
that that could kick in the 30 days
that if it's if it's considered that
that you know the commission is
obviously and I would have to say that
if if someone you know anyone can appeal
a commission's decision they actually
can take it to court if you don't like
the decision but that that if the court
if the commission you know feels the
severity of the case I mean the reality
is you know we don't have a lot of this
thank God in New Hampshire that you know
people dying
um and so every time it does happen it
it does feel severe and it feels you
know uh but that there are extenuating
circumstances and
um the commission definitely does its
homework and and research it and pursues
it like a full legal case in terms of
analyzing it and
representative Terry
yes uh in complete agreement uh Mr
chairman with what you've just said uh
but uh in addition I think to be a bit
more specific conversation was around
recommending that there be a mandatory
minimum
on the second offense of at least seven
days so that the discretion would fall
between seven days and 30 days
thank you bye
and Sullivan I know you care about this
issue do you have any
you want to weigh in on
no I'll be interested to see what they
have I mean
I think we just need to be aware of that
they could be unintended consequences if
we
go really extreme on it and so I'll be
curious to see what the language looks
like I wouldn't be super comfortable
with this potential bill would be
putting restaurants out of business for
an offense or whatever so but you know
so I'll be curious to see what it is we
can have that discussion when it comes I
think that I think everyone generally
agrees if it was if it was the first
offense
it's hard to imagine to go for a full
30-day suspension but the underlying
could the underlying you know situation
been there with such blatant abuse that
they establishment should have known
sure and I think there was other things
that we talked about too like like time
limits like if you have a first offense
this year and then in 2031 we have a
second offense right how the time the
time would be time there's a lot of
things that we talked about that I think
we need to think about just because
we don't want to be like yeah you
a decade passes and they have another
defense is that going to put or whatever
you know something that's been open for
40 years 50 years you don't want to be
like these things are going to happen no
matter what we can't right get rid of it
and I do know that I am sponsored a bill
for the commission that uh is taking
some of the rule making for some of the
license the ones like the tobacco and
taking it excuse me taking it out of
statutory and put it into rule making so
that the department could be a little
more flexible in terms of how they
decide how do we do that so whether you
think that's a good or bad diet idea
we'll be talking about that this next
session
um but I think everything comes down to
see what they've come up
and I know they're working very hard on
getting this concluded
so that would make another one for this
for the
17th
that is 279.
that's six fiddles
okay
otherwise uh enjoy your fall vacation
and we'll see you in a couple weeks
foreign